topic of Mahad comes up. I'm like, "What
you want from Mahad?" She said something
like, "Uh, $3,000." It was like some
gold. I told her, "Listen, I'll give you
$100."
>> Not going to lie, when I heard that, I
was a bit taken back. Yeah, cuz I didn't
understand the context, but it was like
going from $3,000 to $100.
>> Do not forget to check out cindi.com.
Brothers and sisters, one of my most
amazing clothing brands that I wear,
alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims with the
recent boycott that's going on with many
brands, clothing lines supporting
Israel. Brothers Sisters, you guys know
I've been supporting Cindi.com. I've
been wearing their stuff long, long time
ago. Alhamdulillah. And I love their
clothing, brothers and sisters. It's
exactly what I I like. Alhamdulillah,
when it comes to fitness, training,
jogging, just general wear when I'm
praying. I don't need to worry about my
back showing. Buy it for your family
members, your your uncles, your
brothers, your husbands, whoever it is.
Inshallah bro sisters, buy it for
yourself. Inshallah, it's modal
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well and hope you guys
are excited to go through this reaction
video with myself. This is a brother.
Subhan Allah. I know uh myself.
Alhamdulillah. Um, Iron Fit Coach.
Alhamdulillah on Instagram.
Alhamdulillah. You know, alhamdulillah,
I like his content. He talks about how
to be a real man in today's time where a
lot of men are absolute um, how can I
say in a nice way? Wimps. Absolute
wimps. Yes. Okay. Their wives are more
of a man than they can ever be. They've
become wimps. Yes. And I applaud his
content. I don't agree with everything.
Let me be honest with you. For that,
this video will prove that I don't agree
with everything with a brother.
Alhamdulillah does amazing content when
it comes to fitness coaching. He go and
contact me to sign up to his coaching
thing and I said bro I'm already really
really fit alhamdulillah and I went
through some intense thing with
silverback jay hhamdul was 12 kilos got
a bit lean I recommend for all the
brothers please you know coaching etc
when it comes to training sign up to his
brother Silverback Jay and this brother
as well Iron Fit coaching we're going to
react to a video of himself
alhamdulillah like I said before I
encourage a lot of brothers to follow
him um don't follow him blindly but
here's a video of him telling the story
of a sister he was getting to know for
marriage and why that did not go ahead
cuz there are things that I agree with
this one thing that I disagree In I just
wanted to share that with you guys
inshallah and I'm sure the brother will
be watching this inshallah may bless him
in hope he likes he doesn't mind a bit
of criticism inshallah but let's watch
it inshallah brother and sisters here we
go
>> tell you a story there was a sister I
was speaking to for marriage she was
okay we're talking and the topic of mah
comes up I'm like what you want for mah
she said she said something like uh
$3,000 it was like some gold
>> okay so sister he came across a sister
for mah for marriage she's half of the
Quran one thing that I will advise a lot
of brothers who are watching this as
Well, um, that is amazing. Someone who's
half of the Quran, and this might sound
a bit crazy me saying this, and I'll
tell you out of my experience. I have
experience out of inah and in Islam,
both a decade each, you know, in Islam,
more than a decade, 13 years. Uh, and I
am very very experienced in the sense
where when I was looking to get married,
there's things that I went through. I am
going to say something guys, do not ever
put your guard down. And this applies to
the sis as well. Here's a half of the
Quran. She's a heter of the Quran.
Let me tell you something guys. If I was
getting sis for marriage half of the
Quran, I would say okay that's good. May
Allah bless you. That's good for you.
Alhamdulillah. It would be good for me
as well in it depends teaching my kids
etc. But there's something deeper when
it comes to character etc. So do not
ever fall for these things of the outer
appearance or she knows the Quran that
does not mean she is a good person. And
I'm so sorry to say I know many brothers
who are in court with their half of the
Quran wives taking them to court and
saying putting the middle finger to the
Sharia and saying I'm going to man-made
laws and I'm taking your wealth which is
haram and you know before sis come and
say oh I wonder what he done. Yeah. Of
course it's always something he done.
You know he's a narcissist manipulator.
Yeah. Okay. So be very careful. But
let's carry in. So she said she wants uh
$3,000 and some goat which is I believe
it's her huck. She has a right to ask
that and Islam in the Quran. Allah
clearly states that. But let's see what
he had to say. I told her, "Listen, I
told her, "Listen, I'll give you $100."
She was like, "Okay." Not going to lie,
when I heard that, I was a bit taken
back. Yeah. Cuz I didn't understand the
context, but it was like going from
$3,000 to $100. When I watched, I
laughed a bit. I was like, "Okay, look.
I mean, you could be justified, but I
just want to understand where that was
coming from, but let's let's carry on
in."
>> She accepted it. Next day, she calls me
with some doubts.
>> Okay. Interesting. So, she accepted it.
I mean, that is admirable uh or
admirable, how you guys like say that.
So yes, but again I want to stress on
one thing because we have narrations of
for example at the time of Omar bakab uh
for example there was a woman who
famously opposed Omar bakab opinion on
the permissibility of limit of mahari
her name was bbintazid she was someone
who heard that um was given a sermon to
women and scolding them for asking for
yes it was making it hard for for men to
get married
one of the 10 promised ja nobody needs
to give introduction
Now he says this and what happens the
following day in a he's given
gets up and says oh
for example according to a hadith
commentary umar upon hearing of the
marriage where a large man was given
state that women should not be given
excessive diaries however remained
remind him of the verse in the Quran in
chapter 40 4:20 that mentions giving
a large amount as mah effectically
challenging um's opinion and proven him
wrong. Now she stood up and said no with
all due respect that is the Allah
subhana wa ta'ala gave us and we can ask
for whatever we want and I will
reiterate that because to me people call
me you misogynist you always t woman
yeah yeah whatever you know nothing
about my content okay I'm telling you
clearly sisters yes I tell this clearly
yes ask minimum 3,000 free 5,000 minimum
minimum minimum yes you can be merciful
and give them a a a um payment uh plan
yes like my wife did give me a payment
plan alhamdulillah have your mercy
However, it is your hub. Nobody can come
and call you a gold guy. You're looking
for this. You're this kind of person.
No, no, no, no, no, no. But obviously,
don't go to other extreme of certain
silly sisters out there who like I want
£50,000. £50,000 and I want the house
and the dream sister's going to marry
seriously. And this is what happens with
sisters. They live in La La Land. Wai,
they reached the age of 30 and
everything.
Anyways, so let's carry on with the
video. Inshallah. I just wanted to
mention inshallah, which is there's
nothing wrong with the sister. Subhan
Allah. Alise, she admit went down and
said $100. made, you know, obviously she
wants to marry you. She doesn't mind.
That's fine as long as mutually agree to
that matter. But here it gets a little
bit um thin for the brother.
>> I add my friend on the phone call. I was
like, add your friend on the phone call.
Okay, let's see where this goes. So,
it's one of her friends. She's a
29year-old successful businesswoman
making lots of money, 29year-old,
single, never been married. She said,
she's like, "How can you give her such a
low mah and this that and the other?
She's worth more than that and this that
and I was like, what? Why are you even
involving yourself?" Like first of all,
what are you doing?
>> Why are you involving yourself in this?
And so this exposed to me, okay, a lot
of it is there's a lot of good sisters.
This was a good sister, but she had bad
friends around. Misery loves company.
Other single women keep women single.
>> I mean, uh, let's break this down now.
Now, if for example, that sister said no
to $100 m, if she's a good sister, and
I'm not talking about her being half of
the Quran, that I I I personally when it
comes to marriage, that is something
that's between her and the Lord. That's
good for her. Quran. I'm talking about
when you get to marry someone, you are
going to know who they are really about,
guys. You don't understand. You don't
understand. Trust me, I've got a lot of
experience. You don't understand what
really goes on. Be very careful. So,
what I'm saying is to me, if she said,
"No, I want $3,000." And if this brother
said, "No, you're in the wrong." I would
say clear, I don't know if that
happened. I'm just giving hypothetical
situations.
Mah is a huck and she don't ask for
whatever she likes. Do you not disregard
a sister because of that? Yes. However,
s obviously, you know, if you talk about
20, 30, 40, 50,000, keep dreaming. I
don't know what kind of la land you live
in. Okay, it's your hook. You can ask
for it. I'm just saying you're going
into La land now. Okay, now it's getting
a bit ridiculous. Okay, so now this here
issue is very valid. What he said is
very valid. You know why it's not the
issue of mah. I don't think the issue of
mah was at here at hand because he
probably just maybe just tested to see
if she's about, you know, maybe a gold
digger or whatever for that matter. Some
people label them even though they're
not because they can ask or whatever. If
she said $100, he would probably say,
you know, I'm going to give you $3,000
whatever. But her friend getting
involved, it is a red flag, brother. The
biggest red flag let me tell and this
happens amongst women a lot brothers do
not marry a woman who when you have an
issue this that and their friend comes
in you know this friend who's a single
it's always a single friend by the way
it's always single friend and women they
hate they are the biggest competitors to
one another and studies show in Muslim
they have they are evil towards one
another when it comes to gossip you know
and slandering one another they are evil
they hate each other's guts which I
don't know why and this is a fine
example why because the fact that
there's something you agreed If you're
getting your friend involved with a
matter like this, which is something
that we've both agreed on, whatever it
is for that matter, if you're getting
your friend involved with that, oh my
goodness gracious meahill, in marriage,
guys, subhan Allah, if she does this, it
is a massive red flag for any man. And I
don't blame him. I don't blame him for
saying bye-bye. You know why? You may be
she might be a good sister, but this
issue because when women come together
and like we said before, women are
emotional creatures. That's how Allah's
created them. It doesn't make them bad
or evil. That's how they are created. So
they have to be led. I believe in the
nuclear family. They have to be led.
That's why it's so important to obey
your husbands. And I'm talking about a
husband who's good to you. Don't when I
say obey your husbands, please don't
think about your dad who beats your
wife, uh your mom and your ex-husband
who done the please. I'm talking about a
good Muslim man. Alhamdulillah, fears
Allah. So to go and share this, this is
a especially misindependent. Yes, boss
babe slay the day. They like to slay the
day. More likely they slay their life
away. The biggest calamity people are
insulting feminism. Women are insulting
feminism. You know why? Cuz when they
reach the age of 30, 35 m career woman
with nobody in your life and nobody
wants to marry you. You're looking at
the ceiling and counting how many tiles
there are on the ceiling with your Gucci
bag that you made. You know, boss babe.
Yes. And you're going out and you can't
find the right guy because sadly a lot
of women live in La La Land. Absolute La
La Land.
Be real with yourself. Get married when
you're most in your f you're fertile.
You are young. You are beautiful. Men
want you. You are sought after. Make the
most out of that. That's very important.
Do not delay like this single. I'm being
honest with you. Yes, women are jealous
of one another. She probably wants that
girl to stay single like herself. That
is it. Sadly, I'm not saying every
single woman, majority of women, they
are like they're in competition with one
another. So, they don't like it. That's
why when it comes to advising, they
could be on their period and they're
talking of emotion. They had the bad
day, they had the anything and they are
giving you a nsia. That's why I always
tell sisters, go and take nia from a
woman who's in her 40s, married
successfully, who's level-headed on her
dean. Gets from that kind of woman. Any
other woman, I advise brothers all day,
every day. I'm married. I'm telling you,
listen to me. Protect your wife from
these deluded tapped in the head, I call
them crackhead of individual friends
that they call who gives them wrong
advice and they do it subtly. You'll see
if your wife goes to a friend's house
and she comes back and then all of a
sudden you see her, you know, her
attitude change, she's looking
differently, etc. And she brings up
something, best believe, brother. A
conversation that was had there stemmed
to your marriage. These are shin that
destroy marriages. Subhan Allah. And
look, she came in the way of this
prospect. Why? Who are you, brother? Her
solicitor. Hey, look. And even though I
agree that for example, like I agree
with the sentiment in the sense where
it's not about, oh, is she worth that?
No, it could have it should have come
from her, not her friend. It should have
come from her because she showed she
does have some kind of backbone. Why
call your friend? Is she a lawyer? Just
come and say no, brother. I thought
actually. No, I have 3,000. 100%. I will
say all day every day, bro. I'm so
sorry. If she's a good sister, you're
out of your mind, Aki. To say no to a
sister and give her $3,000 or whatever.
I'll be honest with If she's a good
sister, put me in a payment plan,
brother, all day, every day.
Alhamdulillah, like I did with my wife.
So, I would say I don't blame him for
saying no to that. So, in a nutshell,
brothers and sisters, what is my point?
When it comes to marriage, brothers and
sisters, be very careful. Do not ever
think the Quran the the she wears a
Yeah. And a motorbike helmet on top. His
beard is so long it goes all the way to
wherever. Okay. He's got mwak. Yes.
Okay. He can brush everybody's teeth
with it. Okay. Means nada zero. Do not
look at her character, his manners,
relationship with the family. These are
the things and do have a good
relationship with Allah subhana wa tala.
So Allah subhana wa tala can guide you
cuz Allah truly knows who's about what.
Believe me for me my marriage and
anybody for that matter anyone that's
got inshallah cross with Allahh I hope
that I have you leave the matters to
Allahh Allah will always give you
someone that is good for you inshallah.
So that's all I'm going to say in
brothers and sisters and please please
brothers and sisters inshallah be
careful when it comes to marriage. We
are going to be doing an episode soon
when we're going to be prepping uh
giving to those who are looking to get
married inshallah in the best ways with
my experience of I would say 20 years of
10 years of jahal 13 years of Islam. Uh
there's so much that you can learn from
myself and it's for free no courses pay
you this absolutely free till next time.
Do not forget to download the salah pro
app guys. It's a free app, free ads,
free kfinder, salah time, salah
reminders. You can book a salah
instructor, order a guided prayer mat,
find your local salah hub, watch videos
on how to pray salah. The app is
absolutely free on Android, iOS. Till
next time.